well thanks so much everyone welcome
back to campus it's great to have
everybody here my name is Stewart
dequeue on the program director at the
Yale Center for business in the
environment and today we're launching
the first in a six-part series
colloquium and sustainability marketing
and this series is really unique for a
number of perspectives which I'll walk
through describe sort of the general
overview of the series I'm going to
introduce an alum and a sponsor of the
program and then we're gonna get into an
introduction of our moderator who's
going to introduce our featured guest
for today's talk the colloquium and
sustainability marketing at Yale
sponsored by decra aims to unravel and
address the challenges of creating
environmentally sustainable products
services brand and brands that customers
love this will be a six part series
throughout the year exploring multiple
perspectives from leading brands that
are driving this conversation forward in
recent years there has been an explosion
of interest in building brands through
green or cause based marketing given the
current noise and plethora of marketing
approaches the claim that a product is
more sustainable is being critically
evaluated brands making green claims are
being forced to address significant
environmental aspects across their
lifecycle despite all this recent
activity in order to achieve a
sustainable impact substantial impact
products that are more environmentally
sustainable need to be able to reach an
even wider audience and gain even more
market share now this you know this area
of focus is one which is is new to our
Center and new to the Center for
customer insights so this speaker series
is a joint partnership between the Yale
Center for business the environment and
the Yale Center for customer insights
and a lot of the best things around here
happen when a couple of factors come
together and really that's student
initiative pushing us forward to do
different interesting things and alumni
coming back to the program or to the you
know coming back to the school and
saying you know I can support this that
can help I can be a part of this both
creatively and in other ways and so that
really came together within this series
so there are a couple of people I want
to thank before we get started first is
a student who really came to us and has
pushed this for the last year and a half
currently a second year joint degree
student between the Yale School of
Management in Yale's
forestry Marrissa galicia marisa for
those of you you know online you know
you get to see Marisa at a later talk
I'm sure up here announcing but and for
everyone in the audience here she really
spent a lot of time creatively thinking
this through pulling together the
resources and making this happen on
campus and so it's a real testament to
her organizational skills and an
ingenuity Anastasia
O'Rourke who is a PhD graduate of the
Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies at the same time
came to us and was really interested in
creating co-creating and really being
able to develop a new initiative on
campus and Anastasia is a principal at
decra she'll describe a little bit more
of what they do but Anastasia is the
best type of alum that we can we can
offer to the world somebody who's
interesting implementing creative
solutions out in the business world and
then also really interested in exploring
the underpinnings of how things work and
business in the environment and where we
can make an impact here at Yale so she's
really brought an incredible amount of
thought and creativity and input into
this series and we're just thrilled to
have Decker as a sponsor so Anastasia
you'd like to say a few words we are a
global company in 50 different countries
across the range of professional
services I'm in the consulting advisory
group and for starting and working on
building up our North American
sustainability consulting practice a lot
of what we do is on product
sustainability and so that's why I'm
interested in in this series and
especially in hearing from leading
companies like Johnson & Johnson and
we're just thrilled to have you here
really happy to be back and great
kickoff to the series I think so enjoy
so with that I'm going to introduce our
moderator for today's discussion the
nice thing again about all these factors
coming together is then being able to
bring faculty expertise to a discussion
and George Newman is an assistant
professor of organizational behavior at
the Yale School of Management
George is interested in the application
of basic cognitive processes such as
categorization casual reasoning to
consumer behavior and also specifically
he's interested in pro-social behaviors
such as charitable giving and purchasing
environmentally friendly products and
how consumers may balance their desires
to do good with desires to maximize the
efficiency of their donations and
purchases and George really has been
somebody who is a student I was actually
even able to collaborate with the Yale
School of Management and has always been
really generous with his time to
students and people interested in this
space and his a number of research
projects ongoing with the Center for
business in the environment we're
thrilled to have George as a moderator
and I'll pass it off to him thank you
very much Stuart everybody can hear me
all right
yes okay so first I'd like to just
introduce our speakers today as we're
pleased and honored to have al newsy
he's the senior director for the
environment health and sustainability at
Johnson and Johnson he recently
published a book greener products the
making and marketing of sustainable
brands so please join me in welcoming Al
and our second speaker is Keith Sutter
who's the senior product director for
sustainable brand management at Johnson
& Johnson so please join me in welcoming
and then also just as a way of thank you
again to thank Stuart to crew from Yale
Center for Business the environment
Anastasia
Aurora from decra and Heather if it's
jailed for from Y CCI for helping to put
this series together so please join me
in thanking them as well ok so I think
we're gonna have a really fun discussion
today and to kick things off actually
just as a way of a road map here maybe
we'd spend I think we've got about an
hour so maybe a little less now so spend
about 30-40 minutes with a kind of more
structured discussion and then turn it
over to questions from you so around
12:30 I'd like to maybe feel questions
from the audience and if I you know I'm
latched in time please just stick your
hand up in the air and we can talk about
it then
ok so I thought just to kick things off
we could have both Al and Keith just
tell us a little bit about their
backgrounds how they came to Johnson &
Johnson and about the kind of work that
they're doing there now so al do you
want to go first yeah sure
first of all I just want to thank you
and thank Decorah for the opportunity to
be here it's great turnout look forward
to having interesting discussion with
all of you first I just like to
introduce who Johnson and Johnson is as
a company and I'll give you a little bit
about my background so many of you
unless you did some research on already
might think of Johnson & Johnson as a
consumer products company but that is
what we're most well known for but
that's are actually our smaller sector
we have three key sectors so the
consumer products which has some great
brands Johnson & Johnson products maybe
products band-aids Neutrogena
you know clean and clear benadryl
tylenol Mochan those type of brands are
part of our consumer products portfolio
with a whole bunch of others our largest
sector is actually medical device and
Diagnostics
where we make anything from large blood
analyzers that are use in hospitals to
knees and hips
you know replacement knees and hips
cardiology equipment video scopic
surgery equipment a blood glucose
monitor so a whole host of different
types of products there and then our
second largest not not by much is our
pharmaceutical sector and a whole host
of prescription drugs oncology pain
management psychological drugs a whole
bunch of different drugs so that's who
the company is our sales are
approximately seventy billion dollars so
we're huge we have over 250 operating
companies and we operated as a
decentralized company - we've had some
discussions earlier saying how
complicated that could be I'm sure we'll
get some questions questions about that
a little bit about my background so I've
been working for Johnson Johnson for 29
years I started out my career as in
environmental basically of all my
background science and environment so
out of school in New Jersey Stockton
State University some of you may have
heard of I I was recruited to work for
the New Jersey Department of
Environmental Protection and that's how
I got my my role though initially I
wanted to be a forest ranger of the same
yellow school of forestry is a very
interesting place to be but you know
they I was told there was no jobs in
forestry so hey why don't you try it why
don't you pursue pollution control so
sounds good to me and then I kind of
worked out I got a job working for a New
Jersey DEP I kind of got frustrated with
state government and bureaucracy and I
happened to get an opportunity to go to
one Johnson Johnson divisions called
Ethicon Inc which is the world's largest
suture manufacturing facility along with
a whole bunch of other products now -
that's our main brand and then I left
the company for a year as an
environmental consultant so I had got
some expert
um you know can really Anastasia to your
environment a little bit but then I was
asked to come to corporate headquarters
and I've been at corporate headquarters
ever since 1995 and I've worked in
various positions auditing our sites all
around the world so I've been on just
about every continent doing
environmental audits I started our
design for the environment program back
in 1999 and now I'm fully into the
product side so I'm responsible for the
earthwards process which is our process
to make our products greener or more
sustainable that covers all three of our
sectors and we're green marketing which
is Keith row he's our main green
marketer within our company he's
responsible for that spurring that kind
of thinking throughout all of our brand
teams so that's pretty much where we're
a man that's pretty much money you know
in a nutshell what my background is
thank you I also would like to thank
everybody and yell the opportunity to
come here and to have a good
conversation today really appreciate it
by way of background I joined J&J just
about 11 years ago I started as a brand
marketer right out of right out of
school and worked on one of our most
iconic brands bene so I started on
band-aid brand and then worked for the
next eight years within our consumer
products sector on a range of products
everything from a lot of them that I'll
mention Neutrogena some of our other
wound care businesses and including some
products that make meal and took a small
break from J&J also but came back just
over two years ago in this role at our
corporate function to head up
sustainability marketing and earthwards
which is our process for making an arc
and greener products so with my
background in marketing and brand
management I was able to leverage that
the connections I had within the
organization across J&J to help to
understand from a marketing perspective
they're more of a commercial aspect how
do you translate some of the things that
is going on from an R&D and technical
side into benefits that our customers
and consumers really care about so I I
like that word I love my opportunity to
work across all three sectors and across
the enterprise and to see the kind of
magnitude working for a larger
organization
johnson johnson provides so thank you
again for having me i look forward to a
good conversation today great and so you
you both mentioned the earthwards
program I wondered at Keith if you maybe
wanted us to give us a better sense of
what it is you know what are some of the
goals and targets for that program at
Johnson & Johnson sure so provide just a
brief overview and I'll fill any gaps
that I might might leave but back in
2009 the program I'll reference the
design for the environment program there
was a desire Allen and other people
within the organization I hadn't yet
joined this group to pull some of that
together and to brand it to create a one
singular program where all of these
elements could reside and the output of
that exercise was the earthwards process
and earthwards is at its heart it's its
life cycle thinking at our product level
so how do we think about the impacts
that our products have across all of
their life cycles and how do we improve
them it starts with you know and it has
to be flexible enough right to work on
band-aids and blood analyzers so it's
not about a set hurdle rate it's about
continuous improvement how do we show
progress that were for both our
customers consumers and internally
within the organization that we're
making our products better they're
having less of an impact across a range
of attribute areas what are threats has
four steps first step is compliance and
just understanding what's in our product
you know for some of our consumer
products that's quite an easy exercise
you look at the Bill of Materials for
some of them from medical devices it can
be quite complex because you've got
components coming from hundreds if not
thousands of vendors and how do you
understand all the different components
that are going into that so it can be a
rather difficult conversation or
question to answer sometimes next step
is that lifecycle screening so we like
to try to educate all of our
constituents across the enterprise on
where the impacts are that are happening
because often too often our focus is on
what's happening within our facilities
what's happening within jj's factories
what's driving cost of goods but
ultimately the impacts as I'm sure many
people in the room know for a lot of our
products happen outside of our walls
it's either the sourcing if
an agriculturally based product or it
could be in use like a blood analyzer
machine has a lifespan of almost 10
years and uses electricity and water and
creates waste for twenty essentially
operating 24/7 in a hospital environment
for ten years you improve the electrical
efficiency of that product by fifteen
percent you could potentially save that
hospital thousands of dollars of the
life cycle of that product and it's a
huge impact area and that's not
something that a lot of our brand
marketers or our commercial leaders
think about so we educate them on that
step three is identifying improvements
so we have seven at categories where we
measure improvements materials waste
water packaging social innovation and
energy yes we're calling them from
memory but they only needed one one self
and then what we look is we look for
three substantial improvements so we
consider for most of those to be a ten
percent or better so for energy for
waste were you able to reduce the impact
that that products having by ten percent
and we think that that for most of our
products is a pretty substantial
improvement when you're looking again at
the scale on the size of most of our
businesses and the last step in the
process is validation so if the team has
identified three improvements three
substantial improvements they put to
pull together the data substantiate that
they put together a presentation and
they present to an internal and external
board that reviews that so there's a
group of people from within the company
experts on legal marketing product
stewardship as well as external board
members from World Wildlife Fund and
other NGOs to keep us honest in the
process if that board says yep we agree
with your findings we agree with your
data but earthward that product becomes
earthwards recognized and we have a goal
as an organization to have 60 products
across the across the enterprise rich
Steve that recognition by 2015 we're
currently at 44 representing outside you
know I mentioned we're about a seventy
billion dollar company it's over four
billion dollars in total sales of
products that have received directly
so that's an overview George is that hit
the highlights the aligote I miss
anything or it's great all right that
was great I mean maybe Alda you can
speak a little bit to just what were
some of Johnson & Johnson's motivations
into starting a program like this yeah
so it's a couple so I mentioned that and
Keith mentioned this too that we started
design for the environment program back
in 1999 and you know we rolled it out
globally and we had a lot one tool that
we used across all three businesses over
time we realized that you know there
wasn't one size fits all and we needed
to have various tools depending on the
type of products that we were selling so
that also with the advent of more
competition bringing greener products to
market and wanting to be able to better
communicate the greener attributes of
our products to our customers those two
forces coming together and Johnson &
Johnson being in a marketing company you
got to have something with some you know
panache to it in order for people to pay
attention to it internally too as well
as externally for your customer so we
partnered with with the firm to a
consulting firm to look at what other
companies were doing what our customers
are looking at and we we came up with
the concept for earthwards and with a
scorecard and a whole process of how to
how to make more sustainable products
and also how to market it so it's really
got those two components to it it's not
just a tool it also is one of our
objectives is to be able to bring
scientifically-based green marketing
claims to our customers so we wanted a
way to kind of combat greenwashing as
well so that when we do bring statements
to our customers that you know it's
really got some science behind it and
it's gone through a robust review as
Keith detailed through our
review process that's great um I mean
maybe just sticking with that question
you know I think one of the challenges
is in this area it's measuring you know
the efforts of that type of green
marketing how does Johnson & Johnson you
know review those figures what kinds of
data figure into you know counting
something as a win in this space sure
yeah
so one of the things that we've recently
started doing is understanding the
claims that come out of the or through
its process how often are they utilized
so you know there's a lot of components
yeah if for a marketing mix model right
so whether it's green marketing you know
the sustainable attributes there's a lot
of different elements that go into our
customers decision whether it's a
consumer or a hospital into purchasing a
product and sustainability is more
important for some less important for us
you know less important to others but
what we've seen is that if the marketers
are seeing value then they're spending
money to support the and you use those
claims publicly and if they're not using
them that means they're not seeing value
so our marketers are sort of our
barometer if they're dedicating hard-won
advertising or packaging space to those
claims that means it's having an impact
on their business so that's they're sort
of our barometer and we've seen our
utilization rate of claims because we
continue to find ways to partner with
that commercial organization better go
from about 30 percent when we launched
to now upwards over not over 70 percent
so we're seeing a substantial
improvement in terms of the in the
utilization rate of those claims coming
out of the earthwards process and is
that something that that Johnson &
Johnson is also doing internal research
on to kind of say well you know how much
are these types of claims factoring into
individual consumer decisions yeah so
you know actually I think one of the
handouts that and Alan put out on the
table we sponsored a research study last
year that looked globally at hospitals
and their decisions in purchasing more
environmentally preferred product
products EPP processes what we found is
that there's about 20% of customers out
there here in the US that are using EPP
criteria to purchase to make purchasing
decisions it's a contributing factor if
you have a cardiac stent
that is superior efficacy that's gonna
win the day right clear product benefits
but if you have products that are
minimally differentiated and you have
one that is has removed removed latex or
remove PVC or remove the material of
concern or is a more sustainable
packaging you have an opportunity to get
a to get an advantage in the marketplace
and that's something that we've actually
created a valuation model within our MDD
business to understand what are the
risks and benefits of not investing in
developing more sustainable products so
we're starting to value that and have
those conversations with the finance
partners on if we invest in removing a
material of concern or reducing
packaging there's an investment on the
business to do that but the claim that
comes out of that potentially results in
significant market share gains so it
there's always a complex answer but
again the more that if the marketers are
making the decision to use the claims to
me that's a clear indication that it's
it's moving the business because those
bets paces you're paying for it so it's
a finite resource right right maybe just
to follow up there he would both
mentioned the medical industry and the
b2b business is being actually a larger
segment of wonder if you could talk
about how that b2b business differs
maybe from the consumer product size and
some of the different considerations
that might go into that yeah sure first
I'd like to let you know that the survey
or the research that we did is available
online we have an external facing
website for earthwards so if you put in
your browser www-what comm you can get
to our external facing website you can
learn more about earthwards but that
research report is there you can
download that research report and
there's some other examples and there's
some stories and that would have been
written about earthwards if you wanted
to get a deeper dive so b2b marketing
it's interesting I you know in my book I
do a whole section on
do to be marketing and if you really
think about the impact of corporation
cabinet I know a lot of you in the
audience are in some of you are here
here because you want to make a
difference with work and we're seeing
this more and more people are you know
mission centered you know I don't want
to just get a job and get paid for it
you know yeah sure I want to get paid
but I want to do something that's
meaningful with my life right so we're
seeing more and more people who are
interested in these type of things and
we're seeing now a pull in the
marketplace so what I wanted the biggest
drivers there's a lot of drivers for
bringing greener products to market and
to be thinking about this this type of
stuff in if you look at society right
now there's a finite amount of resources
we're going to see more resource
constraint as the middle class grows in
India and China we're all the raw
material is going to come from right so
we're going to see more of a competition
for that and more of a struggle to to
get that and of course probably coming
up so we're gonna have to do things
differently from a product development
standpoint but the the power of a
corporation to do good is tremendous so
if you look at like a company like like
Johnson and John so you take other major
companies like Procter & Gamble you know
Unilever we all have like major
sustainability initiatives and if you
think about our supply chain like Keith
alluded to one of our devices you could
have thousands of parts and think about
where those thousands of parts coming
and all the different companies that are
involved in in providing to that that
part you know that which goes into a
greater you know part if we can get our
supply chain to start thinking more in a
sustainable manner start doing the type
of things that we're trying to do with
earthwards you know life cycle thinking
reducing the impacts throughout the
supply chain we could do our tremendous
good and to me the the greatest force of
us of companies initiating
sustainability programs is not
government a lot of people think like
the old mindset when I hadn't went for
environmental science back in the 80s
when I got my degree it was all you know
government regulation that was that was
driving things
well government regulation is like at
the bottom of the list I mean it's
important don't get me wrong but it's
really market drivers that are creating
these things and it's ties into the
whole b2b thing so who's our largest
customer
our largest customer in the world is
Walmart so if you look at Walmart I'm
sure anybody who's looked at
sustainability at all they're just
bought you know Walmart says speaks
people listen you know like the old EF
Hutton commercial and we are if we're
interested in meeting our customers
demands we're going to you know pay
attention to what they say and they've
put out these sustainability goals just
like we have to you know and we have
goals on our supplier so our key
suppliers were asking them to adopt
sustainability goals we're asking them
to report and the Carbon Disclosure
Project so you know if you want to get
an edge to sell products to another
company this is one of the ways to get
an edge and we're seeing more and more
companies you know they have scorecards
on choosing who their most you know
preferred providers and in the b2b
context you could potentially you know
get an edge over your competition by
having better sustainability benefits of
your product or be able to help your
your customer meet their sustainability
goals I wondered that actually you
mentioned that your book if you could
talk about some other companies that you
think are kind of getting this right in
the space you know and have similar
types of initiatives yeah so in my book
I have about 25 case studies I really
love to do they look at what other
companies are doing and the kind of way
that I came to want to write this book
is because we did a lot of benchmarking
of other companies that's how you learn
you know you look at your competition
you look at companies and other sectors
and to me like if I look at like the
gold-plated program when it comes to
making and marketing sustainable brands
I look at GE ecomagination I mean
everybody in this room has probably seen
something about GE echo imagination a
commercial or you know something in in
print media they did a great really
great job in that you know and if you
look at like some companies you might
not think about like what how could a
chemical company so one of the companies
that I that I did a review on is BASF
you know a German based chemical company
they have a whole really good robust
green marketing program they're selling
materials to other companies and using
sustainability as a differentiator
likewise DuPont
is also so I'm trying to shy away from
some of the consumer product ones but
the ones that you know we were talking
about before the type the ones that you
typically who do you think of when you
think of the you know the greenest
companies you typically like seventh
generation or method you know and
they're doing a great job with this too
I mean have the mantra of your company
you know think about your your impacts
to the seventh generation you can't get
much more sustainable thinking than that
out there so those are some of the
companies you know when I look at
benchmarking that that I think of but
I've got a whole host from a whole bunch
of different sectors in the book that
you can learn from from anybody and
there's a lot of green marketing going
on and a lot of green or product
development going on out there you
mentioned a lot of different companies
that seem like they're making
improvements and in a lot of different
areas I wonder a Keith of you kid that
they speak to the following so Dan Esty
here at the fortune School has talked
about how you know consumers tend to
only kind of look at things in their
immediate sphere focus more on maybe you
know packaging and miss pozole less on
material sourcing and transportation so
I wonder from kind of a brand management
side a marketing side how you guys think
about maybe communicating some of those
other types of benefits right yeah so
what I'll say is sometimes it is
challenging because a number of our
products would go through that lifecycle
assessment you'll what we've seen
through the earthwards process is that
almost every product makes improvements
on packaging especially the consumer
products why even though though it might
be a low impact area for many of our
products it's the one that the consumer
cares most about because the last thing
they see when your product is empty is
where does it go do I
you know Acuvue is a great example it's
an technically M D and D but it's a
pretty consumed Erised brand one-a-day
one of the biggest issues that a lot of
consumers have is why can't I recycle my
Acuvue package there's a key blue
packages by the way they're like teeny
tiny you sort of even if you stack up
three and sixty five of them it's still
not that much of an impact in the
aggregate but from a consumer perception
standpoint is that immediate sphere
that's where I think some of the
conversations on it's challenging in the
canoe
interspace but that's where the b2b
conversations where we can have them at
a deeper level you have those more
in-depth conversations with hospitals
who are making decisions through RFP
processes through supplier driven
decisions that's where we can have a
deeper conversation around you know what
happens not just in that immediate
sphere but what are the impacts for us
reducing packaging on trucking for
Walmart it's not just trucking for us
but it's also through their supply chain
and in impacting the store shelf you
know stock out rates that sort of things
so I don't hope Follette gets so the
question is that sometimes you can't
sometimes you have to just focus on what
they're gonna gravitate towards and that
is from the consumer perspective often
what's within their immediate sphere
know ad but I mean I think it's a great
point because you know sometimes we
don't focus on the b2b business and
playing a very necessary role there
right so you know there's a lot going on
even with like the Earthforce come
campaign and I wondered maybe L if you
could speak to how from an
organizational perspective you're able
to advance a campaign like that and a
company as large as Johnson & Johnson
and what are maybe some of the
challenges there the session and J&J is
decentralized management so we have
multiple you know companies multiple
boards so how do you do that we're kind
of fortunate like our department we have
very robust
sustainability programs because it's
kind of ingrained in our credo that
Johnson Johnson credo it actually says
in our credo which we pay a lot of
attention to matter of fact I was just
at a meeting last week where we had a
whole session just on our credo for our
top leaders in our organization it says
that you know we should protect the
natural resources which were privileged
to use you know so that's that's a
that's part of our of our culture so we
have that and we've been collecting data
and doing reporting on sustainability
since the early 90s a matter of fact our
first publicly facing we could
categorize it as a sustainability goal
was in nineteen
sex which was removed was to reduce
toxic chemical emissions and our first
sustainability report was published I
believe in 1993 so we've been we've had
an infrastructure to collect data to get
business units to report and to be able
to show what the enterprise impact is
and all the things that we're doing both
good and and challenges too so we have
knowing knowing that that was in there
one of the ways that we tried to get the
earth which processes that we embedded
it into our sustainability goals so
right now we're on a business rhythm of
every five years we come up with new
sustainability goals our current set of
goals is healthy future 2015 so like all
major companies you could go to our
website and you can download that
sustainability report and one of our
goals as Keith mentions is have 60
earthwards recognized products by the
end of that gold period which is 2015 so
that's you know in graining or embedding
it into business processes like our
sustainability goals is one but that
wasn't that's not enough I mean we
basically I mean Keith is you know one
of the smartest moves we ever did was
hiring Keith on our staff because having
marketing you have to market internally
an external at time you only think that
marketers are helpful in selling your
brand but internally you have to
convince the brand's and we have to
develop case studies we have to show
them why the earthwards process is
meaningful how this can benefit and and
brand teams I mean they're so busy they
can't really focus on these things you
would think that it's second nature to
for them but sometimes they're not even
listening to the right channel is that
where sustainability is coming like if
you look at our our hospital customers
they were focusing on like the physician
the physicians like at the lowest end of
our spectrum is interested in
sustainability but now we're seeing more
institutional purchasing and a material
manager to purchasing groups they're the
ones were more interested in
sustainability what it could do so you
have to like build the business case
externally you have to market it
internally you have to embed it into the
business process there's a whole mess of
things and and even Keith has done some
pretty pretty good work and trying to
get even through our intranet website
and making that more meaningful and
driving more traffic to that and doing
like social media internal to our
company as well as external so there's a
whole mess of things that
you know I'm just really scratching the
surface on it that you have to do in a
company like ours to get it you know
it's quite words is quite different than
let's say GE echo imagination you can
hear Jeff Immelt the CEO of GE speak
about echo imagination you know it
started with it was his idea you know
it's a lot easier to get something done
the CEO says thou shalt you know do echo
imagination you say there buzz and let's
start working on us that where we came
from a different perspective where it
was like a grassroots effort bubbling up
and now it's getting much more uptake
from our different sectors than they're
seeing the benefit and it's taken a lot
of work and effort to to demonstrate and
to try to ingrain it into into the way
the company's working I'll just maybe
add briefly I think that too from like a
change management process approaching it
like a change management problem one of
the ways that we turn this
decentralization which can sometimes be
challenging to operate in to our
advantage is to make it internally
competitive so we I focus a ton on
rewarding and getting recognition
creating social capital for the people
that are make doing this work so the
engineer who pushes to get recycled
content into suture packaging because it
was a side project and something she was
just passionate about making it a huge
point to get hurt internal like I said
what we call standards of leadership
award which is a big deal
it's like a 2% of her salary you know
she gets recognized it's a big deal and
going after that and getting that
building that social capital so that we
can create a competitive environment of
well what's going on over you know the
down the street I see that they're
getting you know recognized for this you
create senior leaders to say well hey
guess what we're gonna be doing this
over here now I want to see I want to
see earthwards recognitions coming from
our products I want to see why aren't we
making improvements here and you start
getting that competitive spirit going
which is one of the advantages of being
a decentralized company is we can ignite
that competitive spirit yeah when we
send out a recognition email this new
brand just received earthwards
recognition you'll see an email go out
and then when the VP's get it they send
it around to everybody hey
congratulations well people kind of get
like
that way also in our internal
newsletters we Keith will get articles
written that we just look at one on a
train right up here that was put on on
some Neutrogena natural brand that
received the earth words recognition how
it was in their consumer newsletter and
then we put it into our broader J&J
newsletter and well that type you know
like I said there's a lot of different
elements that go into it's not just one
one thing that you have to do so
thinking about the the employment side
and maybe I'll make this my last
question I think it'd be really
fascinating to hear from both you you
know there's a lot of people in the room
who are considering careers in this
industry and just to get your thoughts
on where do you see this industry in ten
twenty years and right now you could
play a trend forecaster what's gonna be
the next step maybe a big thing here mmm
well I guess I'll start I'll let Keith
go in this is another thing we discussed
also before so I sustainability isn't
gonna go away can't go away really if
you if you think about it what I
mentioned there earlier as far as you
know resource scarcity the the stresses
on on the earth the growth of population
and there's just so many other forces on
major corporations and even you know
midsize and smaller companies to to do
things this way I mentioned the greening
of the supply chain type of initiatives
which major companies and you fear is
sell them to anybody else which
everybody is there's going to be that
force going on there's a whole bunch of
other forces like annual shareholder
resolutions is another one so every
company major companies gets at least a
couple shareholder resolutions on
sustainability or environmental issues
so if you're like us like a comment in
which I'm sure all major companies they
try to manage that process and it if we
hear that there's a stakeholder who's
interested in something or has concerns
about something we try to talk to them
upfront so it doesn't become a
shareholder resolution you know and try
to you know show them what we're doing
or maybe there's misinformation or
whatever or maybe
you agree to do certain certain thing so
you got that force you've got these
indexes now stock indexes for companies
like the Dow Jones Sustainability Index
a footsie for good index where we're
seeing more and more pension plans or
other major purchases of stock who are
looking at I want to purchase stock from
socially responsible companies so
there's all this whole industry very
large industry billions of dollars of
you know shares of stock are being
purchased based on sustainability
metrics and we pay a lot of attention to
like the Dow Jones Sustainability Index
it's one of our key metrics how we're
doing regarding sustainability and
making sure we stay on a Dow Jones
Sustainability edge so you got all these
forces coming at you you know and that's
just to say that you know the field of
sustainability or environment I don't
see it going away but you know as far as
jobs in the field that's you know
there's definitely a growth in the job
market and seeing more and more
companies starting to need specialists
in this area but I think I what if I was
to predict you know and this is just my
own personal opinion I would say that
it's going to probably reach a plateau
where those type of jobs and then
sustainable is going to be more like
ingrained in the way you do business I
think there's always gonna be a need for
people like us to be driving it to be
focusing on it to stay attuned to what's
going on extremely dynamic I mean if you
look at sustainability a lot of times we
just think of it as an environmental
issue but it cuts across every aspect of
our business you know how our hiring
practices are selling practices how we
treat our employees you know everything
regarding the safety of our employees
you know it just it cuts across so many
different elements and we're judged on
that too by these outside groups that
it's got to be ingrained into the
organization and there's gonna have to
be somebody who's kind of like watching
it and trying to you know keep on
setting new goals new targets steering
the company in the right direction and
looking ahead what you know finding out
what's the next big thing or emerging
issue that could affect the company so I
think it probably will reach a plateau
but I also think that it'll be a part of
a lot of people's jobs so you might be
working in marketing and maybe you're a
brand manager but you're also gonna be
paying attention to sustainability or
you might
be an engineer in manufacturing they're
going to be looking at well how can I
make this process more sustainable you
know and it'll be part of the way I do
business
yeah I think what I would just add is
that the most important thing is when
you're deciding where to go work will
that organization support your desire to
opt to to you know to work in a more
sustainable manner to create more
sustainable products is that going to be
rewarded is that going to be fostered is
that going to be supportive and if it's
not that probably is the biggest
indicator and I think asking real
questions not just are you you know in
the interviews asking for examples of
those senior managers when you're
talking to them how have you made
decisions that have impacted or lessened
your you know you lessen your products
where do you supported your employees to
gain education or awareness or to you
know grow in this area and increase
their knowledge set so I think that's
that's probably arguably the most
important I think J&J is pretty clear
with its credo which is this year 70
years old so created the change that al
mentioned you know it was pretty
visionary when it was written almost 70
years ago now and it is really ingrained
into the business processes and it's
something that is supported across the
across the business I think that's the
most important if you're working for a
company that is maybe saying the right
things but not you know it's actions
aren't backing that up I think that's
probably a bigger a bigger concern
because then you can join the
organization as you know in finance or
marketing or communications or wherever
your functional skill set interests lie
and your passions are going to be
supported as you help that business
become more sustainable thank you both
so maybe at this point I'd like just to
turn it over to the audience does
anybody have any questions for a Lurky
do we you have a microphone or great if
you could say your name and your
affiliation please okay
sure hi I'm my name is Kelly I'm a
master student at the School of Forestry
thank you very much this has been really
fascinating I have a follow-up question
about what where the discussion ended
actually currently you were well you
were talking about how currently having
a sustainability plan and having these
goals can increase market share but
Alice you were talking about eventually
sustainability will just be a natural
part of business I'm wondering then how
how does sustainability add to market
share or help grow market share if
everyone's doing it how do you
differentiate your version of
sustainability from theirs yeah so
there's always gonna be somebody doing
it better than the competitor were they
might have you know better marketers you
know that's part of it too like I have
this saying I said what good is a
greener product if nobody knows about it
right so that's why people like Keith
and marketers I mean it's probably a
decent amount of you you know who are
pursuing their career marketing are like
critical and we belong to this one
organization we go to this awesome
conference every year called sustainable
brands out in California and it's all
about how marketers can make a
difference in the world by you know
marketing sustainability because
actually the marketers are the key to
our success because when they start
asking for these attributes in the
products we start building it that way
you know everybody else listens to
marketers Raziel excluding to the
marketplace that's that's their job so I
think there always will be you know
there's always going to be a
differentiator in products I mean we're
never gonna get you know completely to
that but I think certain things will
have to be you know part of it I mean
you're seeing that look at look at them
like energy store right you know that
EPA programs probably the most wildly
successful program ever developed by a
regulatory agency on the planet I would
say so kudos to you EPA if now it's like
commonplace like you know almost every
device I mean when we go in my family
looking for a new refrigerator first
thing you know and my wife that isn't in
the environmental field and she'll want
to make sure it's got the Energy Star
logo that's top step one before we look
at anything else other features you know
it's got to have that in it
I don't want to use less energy because
it's good for your mind but also saving
money to my electricity quest so you
know that's a perfect example of how
that is there but you still can
differentiate a refrigerator can't you
that's as Energy Star on it so that's
probably you know the best example I
could give you hi um I'm a first year
student at the Business School and I'm
just curious about how cost factors into
this because I imagine that some of
these changes to provide better
sustainability also require perhaps a
change in cost of your product so when
you're faced with proposing that change
how does that factor in and how are
those decisions made especially in the
medical device industry such a
significant change could mean a really
FDA and so forth so how do you kind of
manage that change to make sure that
it's still within your cost profile yeah
sure um so what I'll say is that our
customers so what we're I think maybe
the thinking was in consumer even as
recently as two or three years ago is
the consumer would pay a premium for
more sustainable products numbers batted
around and I remember consultants
telling me ten or fifteen percent right
turns out you know won't pay more for
sustainability hospitals zero cost
premium of there are some extreme
exceptions so there are a couple of
hospitals who are paying a very slight
premium for de HP free it intravenous
systems for their NIC use right so
they'll pay because of the highly
vulnerable patient base there they'll
pay for a slight premium that is the
rare rare exception so what we've done
actually one of the biggest areas of
earthwards sort of mining that we do is
with teams working on cost improvement
projects so how do we how do we take
cost out of our system because if you're
taking cost out of a product typically
you're gonna make be making it more
sustainable so it's it's a win-win so
what we do is we try to embed it early
there's sort of a two-fold answer here
embedded early in the process because
that's when you're you can have
impacts at the lowest cost impact the
products already approved in the market
especially in medical device to your
point getting it really it's a not it's
a non-starter almost always but if you
can build it in early enough you can
find a way to build it in an often and
think broadly you can often save money
you can find ways to deliver cost
synergies or to deliver cost
improvements and then on redesign we're
constantly looking at how can we improve
the cost base for our products and
there's teams CIP teams that are tasked
with delivering millions of dollars to
savings through raw material savings we
partner with them to find ways to save
their to and what we do is we
dimensionalize not only the raw material
savings but also the environmental
benefits to us and to our customers
answer the question I just I was given a
note here also to let our online
participants know that they can write in
questions in the chat box and responded
okay so you had
hi my name is Sarah Smith I'm a joint
degree student with the School of
Management in School of Forestry you
talked a lot about designing earthwards
how it works can you talk about the
decision to make it a complete Lee
internal program as opposed to using an
external standard that might have more
recognition from consumers or others who
are judging your products and how
sustainable they are it seems to me
there are a lot of trade-offs there and
how you would design that program and
the benefits of going one way or the
other
yeah first of all we didn't we there is
no external program that we felt that
could we could adopt to be a star to
earth words and I still would agree with
that statement
what we what we do is we do evaluate
echo logos that could be put onto
products like we have some products that
are in the skin Navy region where you
use the Nordics Quan on it we have some
business units that look and I created a
cradle as an echo logo we use the FSC
certified paper as an echo low so it
depends on it but if but to your point
that consumers would recognize now also
in my in my book I did a section on echo
logos and there's been some research
there's like 400 different echo logos
out there so there's a lot of you know
mass confusion out there and if you look
at the US population of last study that
I saw there's only three echo logos that
are recognized by 50% or higher on the
population you know could you guess
which ones are there you know recycling
symbol which is it Elaine batt Energy
Star one which is really really high
which is amazing which goes back to what
I said earlier and then the USDA
certified organic and then everybody
else is like the next best ones like 44
percent so there isn't really anything
as that really it depends so what we've
kind of I think concluded right Keith is
that the main thing like we don't market
or buy this product is it's earthwards
recognized we market it on what has
improved so what do our customers really
want to know across the board all three
of our sectors they want to know that
we're paying attention to these issues
they want to know that they're getting a
high quality product and they could
trust what they're getting and the way
that we
at least in the sustainability areas
having some scientifically based you
know third-party approved claims that
that were saying this product is you
know a hundred percent PCR or this
product is the packaging is 100% FSC
certified paper board where this product
is free of PVC you know whatever if this
is a Rojas compliant product years
before it's it's required to be those
type of statements or the things that
you know and actually if you want to see
a good really good example I think of
green markings if you go to our
Neutrogena Naturals website I think they
do an excellent job of green marketing
that because they're hitting what's
important to the customer you know they
want to have a natural product that they
could trust from a brand that they can
trust and they actually the claims and
the statements that they make are the
type of things that the consumer is
interested in you know it's like free of
parabens and things things like that it
there's a a closed marketing
relationship with the Nature
Conservancy's and whenever you buy that
product you're helping to support clean
water products products projects so it
ties into what the consumer is looking
for so you know they're it's a long
answer to say there is no not out there
but it was good to give you a little bit
background I think so you could see what
our that we know we thought about that
would have been great if there was just
something we could say let's do this and
we're still looking for human Echo logos
that we could we could partner with to
say oh once this product is earthwards
rec and isaac automatically gets this
echo logo well we haven't found anything
yet yeah I mean again I just think they
dab by making it internally focused
there's a lot of there's also a lot of
risk with the new FCC FCC green guys
regulations around self certification
around echo logos we don't want to add
to that confusion house example of
Neutrogena Naturals all those products
are was recognized earthwards played a
huge role to process in terms of
developing those products from the
beginning you know building it in from
like from the very start on what was in
the formulations what were the claims
that we were gonna make and but yet
nowhere on Neutrogena Naturals website
where we see that their earth words
recognize now what when you wear you
will see it is in when they go to
sell a new item into Walmart there's a
slide in there about how the earthwards
how the product is earthers recognized
and where are the improvements packaging
reductions formulation impacts once it
goes down the drain so that it's having
less of an impact on on store on water
waterways those sorts of things so
earthwards is coming up in there's
customer conversations again b2b versus
b2c we actually have a question online
and it's how do you see this playing out
in developing countries where you're
trying to build brands to earthers
recognized products are actually
relatively split between our developing
and our developed markets we're getting
quite a few from the US and Europe but
we're also getting a lot of great
innovation coming out of the developing
markets specifically there's a line of
surgical devices that has earthwards
recognition that's developed
specifically for the developing markets
for this sort of secondary s to markets
where we can't you know cost won't allow
a $300 stapler like it's just not not
possible for that to function in that
marketplace they've designed a product
that can be 19 depending on the product
it's somewhere between 90 and 95 percent
of the product is reused up to 200 times
it can be effectively steam sterilized
on-site in hospitals with other devices
and they sell just a cartridge that is
re it's that's the sort of the
single-use component of it so you're
reducing material used by almost 95%
you're reducing cost
now there's trade-offs you know those
those devices because they have to be
designed to withstand sterilization 200
times you're making trade-offs it's
heavier it's harder to fire these are
trade-offs that most Western doctors
aren't willing to make at this point you
know was developing countries aren't
willing to make but for the secondary
market where the alternative is hand
suture and failure rate on hand suture
and some of these procedures is 2% and
you can and when you get failure it can
often lead to in fact
to death if you can cut that failure
rate to a half a percent which is what
it's doing
you're saving literally thousands of
people's lives every year which is
tremendous and and we're we have a great
Innovation Center just outside of
Shanghai where our medical device teams
are working with those secondary the
physicians in those secondary markets in
China and India to develop those tools
that are typically making sort of
quantum leaps in terms of how you
deliver the basic needs of the customer
would do it at a fraction 1/10 a 20th a
thirtieth of the cost of what we do it
for in Europe or the US oh yeah Alex
pasa la place at the School of
Management along the same lines I was
curious if you could speak to the
dynamics of what you do and how that
plays out marketing products or just
doing marketing in different countries
sure any anything in particular
sure so you met most of the examples I
guess we're about the US market when you
mentioned one of the echo logos in in a
scandinavian market and i guess i'm
curious about how your jobs are affected
by the was the customer base in
different countries or the the landscape
of sustainability marketing in a
different place like Canada where I'm
from okay
yep no and I think it's a great question
I think it's it's one that where you
have to meet the needs of the local
region so whether it's China
Ross compliance to meet regulate
regulatory needs there or its you know
the Nordic Swan logo in Scandinavia we
have a great baby brand in France called
La Petite my CA
Jane J is the leader in baby products in
every market in the world and if we if
it's not Johnson's we have bought the
leader so so in France we bought the
leader
we just went about them but let's eat
mercy is a great brand if you're from
France or have ever been there
and we've worked with that brand because
it's very fruit and fragrance based so
for them it's they use a lot of natural
extracts so they've actually gone and
created a campaign with an NGO to
protect aro
sort of heirloom varieties of orchards
of peaches and tomatoes and and
different plant extracts that go into
their products as a way to demonstrate
to their customers that they're sort of
living the promise of you know
protecting this natural heritage of
these fruit and fragrance as essences
that are sort of core to their equity so
it is about adapting what's important to
the local audience what's important to
them and and figuring that out and
translating that and then sharing those
best practices right so Nordic Swan is a
great way that you know we were able to
share that case study and work with our
OCD business which is worth of clinical
Diagnostics to make blood analyzers they
we we help them to identify GREENGUARD
which is indoor air quality
certification as something that was
relevant for hospitals because those lab
techs are working in these these lab
spaces and hospitals and they're very
confined sometimes and indoor air
quality and indoor noise is an issue and
GREENGUARD was a certification that was
relevant for a number of hospitals so
we're able to identify them and match
them up and I think they actually just
publicly announced that they were able
to get green card certification on one
of their earthwards recognized products
so hope that is cool we have time for
one last question well so we have one
online if that's all right
I'll mentioned employees wanting
meaningful work as a growing driver for
sustainability initiatives has anyone
measured this driver and other examples
of this driver impacting strategy I
don't know about the measurement maybe
you know keys but I will tell you so I
had this opportunity last year thanks to
Keith to get maybe it was earlier this
year and I remember anyway we had do
this big recruiting event it's called
the J&J Global Invitational where they
invite the you know best and brightest
that are considering joining J&J
out there and they kind of wine and dine
them and try to encourage them to join
our company and we had a session on
sustainability which I did thanks to
Keith I did like eaten one day I think
eight one hour sessions I said I'm gonna
have it by lozenger just to make it to
the end of the day but these students
are extremely interested in this we see
that comment up then I don't know if we
have hard data but I mean just it's just
like a known fact that that you know
students are interested in doing
meaningful work for a company that's
doing meaningful things and that operate
in a socially responsible manner and
that that you know those sessions were
very well attended there were students
from all over the world and they were
asking questions and they're very much
attuned and that time that air time is
precious you know because we're trying
to sell J&J to these students so that's
probably the freshest indicator you know
that that I could give in that regards
and I know they are recruiting also uses
our sustainability brochures to help you
know show students what a perspective
you know employees what we're all about
and how this is meaningful and then show
that we actually pay attention to these
things and get recognized for five third
parties I don't know if you know any
yeah I can I known it impact does a
number of studies every year that they
sort of dimensionalize this and the
impact that it has on recruiting and our
recruiting group does pay attention to a
lot of the sites that a net impact puts
out we have a small presence that the
net impact conference every year so I
know net impact does have some studies
online that show that as well as I'm
just not remembering what the numbers
are right off the top of my head I'm
sure you guys have inspired lots of
people here Dawson think about J and J
so please join me again in thanking uh
Keith and Alfred donating other